alors l'islamisation de la france la
laïcité des thèmes de campagne
privilégiée par les uns quasi ignoré
parfois par les autres on en parle avec
eric revel éditorialistes rt france
bonsoir et les crevettes même si d'être
avec nous alors cette question de
l'islamisation on voit qu'elle déchaîne
en tout cas les passions un jour oui sk
vase et toujours avec ces sujets là est
ce qu'elle est finalement toujours l'un
des grands enjeux de la campagne parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat
peut-être un peu moins de ses sujets
aujourd'hui oui vous avez raison quand
eric zemmour et rentrer en campagne il a
mis sur la table le thème de
l'immigration est d'ailleurs beaucoup de
gens ont pris position sur ce thème
alors on l'a entendue dans ce débat mais
aussi des gens de gauche j'ai vous
donner deux exemples manuel valls ancien
premier socialiste avait publié une
tribune dans le figaro où il disait à
l'époque stop au regroupement familial
donc ça veut dire que manuel valls
anciens premiers ministres socialistes
prenaient très au sérieux la question
migratoire michel barnier qui étaient
présents dans là primaire républicain
mais kate un gaulliste social avait eu
cette formule il faut que la france
recouvre sa souveraineté migratoire
tient de nouveau ce thème en début de
campagne était présent et puis je vais
vous donner un autre exemple peut-être
le plus frappant qui essuient d'un
géographe christophe guilluy qui avait
publié ce livre la france périphérique
et qui avait dit dans une interview au
point quelque chose d'absolument
surprenant sans doute pour quelqu'un de
gauche ils avaient dit les classes
moyennes nous on a longtemps parlé de la
question migratoire ou de la société
multiculturelle mais nous n'avons pas
voulu les entendre
donc ça veut dire que en début de
campagne eric zemmour avait visé juste
en obligeant finalement toute la classe
politique française c'était pratiquement
le seul candidat vraiment déclaré à ce
moment là à se positionner sur la
question migratoire s'est pas mentir
puisque je j'entendais vos invités qui
parlait de mensonges et de vérité ce
n'est pas mentir que de dire que
certains quartiers dans certaines villes
ont été
totalement investie par l'islam
politique ce n'est pas un mensonge c'est
une réalité maintenant aujourd'hui vous
avez raison stéphanie il me semble et
d'ailleurs zemmour a fait un virage sur
l'ale à son meeting de lille samedi
dernier en fait ce qui l'a mis en avant
c'est le thème du pouvoir d'achat parce
que encore une fois dans tous les
sondages d'opinion qui interroge les
français la question du pouvoir d'achat
arrivent en numéro un suivi de la
question de la sécurité puis la question
de l'immigration d'ailleurs la question
de la sécurité ou les sens du but plus
de 60% des français considèrent que la
situation sécuritaire en france ne s'est
pas améliorée ces cinq dernières années
donc c'est un vrai sujet pour le miso
l'intérieur gérald darmanin mais c'est
un vrai sujet aussi pour le président
macron qui va être candidat à sa propre
succession alors oui pardonnez moi je
faisais coupé mais l'islamisation en
parler c'est un sujet on l'a vu que dont
s'est emparé essentiellement la droite
avec parfois quelques surenchère même
oui parce que vous avez un match du côté
de la droite nationale entre eric
zemmour et marine le pen ça n'a échappé
à personne
7cette mouvement ce mouvances politiques
représentent environ 28 à 30 % quand
même hein ce qui n'a jamais été aussi
haut en france donc on peut avoir deux
considérations différentes on peut
considérer que c'est parce que les
hommes ou les femmes politiques mettent
des thèmes politiques sur la table que
les français y adhèrent ou au contraire
et c'est plutôt ma position parce que
les français considèrent que ces thèmes
sont importants et que les femmes ou les
hommes politiques qui les portent
méritent qu'on les écoute moi je n'ai
jamais cru si vous voulez que des thèmes
descendait comme ça d'un programme d'un
candidat et que les français y
adhéraient si ça ne correspondait pas à
leurs réalités donc le thème migratoire
n'en déplaise à plein de bonnes âmes
c'est un thème qui inquiète les français
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que valéry
giscard d'estaing l'ancien président
république française qui avait opté pour
le regroupement familial avait exprimé
un jour le fait qu'ils avaient sans
doute commis une erreur on en est dans
cette situation n'est as dans cette
situation là on est à ce point là
maintenant ce qu'on veut aussi entendre
une fois qu'elle annulera qu'on sera
revenu de moscou
kiev est de berlin c'est qu'on entende
les propositions du candidat macro
notamment sur cette question et je vous
rappelle qu'il a positionné assez haut
dans l'agenda de président du conseil
européen qui l'assument pendant six mois
emmanuel macron la question des
frontières de schengen
si la question des fonds des frontières
de schengen extérieur est abordée ça
prouve bien que le président république
qui va devenir candidat va prendre cette
question migratoire à bras le corps et
qu'il n'en fera pas simplement d'un
revers de main une question subalterne
d'accord mais là vous parler du futur
mais enfin le passé il a même déjà été
président de la république quel est son
bilan à écouter son bilan dès l'instant
où il veut essayer de redéfinir
peut-être les frontières de schengen ça
prouve qu'il n'est pas satisfait de son
bilan l'immigration illégale
c'est un vrai problème en europe on le
sait via l'italie on le sait via la
grèce on le sait via l'espagne il ya des
enclaves où beaucoup de travailleurs
illégaux parfois au prix de leur vie en
traversant la méditerranée essaie de
rallier l'europe on le sait dans le nord
de la france 62 de migrants illégaux et
c'est de passer la manche pour rejoindre
la grande bretagne d'ailleurs on a
oublié tout ça mais il ya quelques
semaines à peine le gouvernement
britannique avait mis solennellement en
garde le gouvernement français il ya un
traité de protection des frontières
entre la france et la grande bretagne et
le gouvernement britannique par la voix
de boris johnson et sa mise l'intérieur
qui lui succédera peut-être avait dit si
vous continuez les français de laisser
passer des bateaux avec des migrants qui
traversent la manche pour aller en
grande bretagne nous ferons ce qu'on
appelle du push back c'est à dire que
nous repousserons ces bateaux pour que
vous vous les accueillir en france donc
ce sujet de l'immigration au-delà de la
polémique politicienne des extravagances
des outrances des uns et des autres
c'est un thème central pour l'europe
évidemment pour la france et je vois pas
comment au delà la question du pouvoir
d'achat on pourra faire l'économie dans
les débats de la présidentielle de
traiter ce sujet la plupart des
candidats en tout cas l'ont déjà bien
compris certainement merci eric revel et